let's do a few more examples of solving
radical equations so let's say I have
the square root of x plus 2 minus 2 is
equal to 0 so just like I said in the
last video we always want to isolate the
radical and the best way I can think of
doing it over here is adding 2 to both
sides of this equation so if you add 2
to both sides of this equation we are
left with the square root of x plus 2 on
the left hand side this cancels out is
equal to 2 and once you isolate one of
the radicals then you're ready to
essentially square both sides of this if
we're dealing with a square root we
square both sides of this so let's do
that
so let's square both sides of that
equation and then we get square root of
x plus 2 squared is just X plus 2 is
equal to 2 squared is equal to 4
subtract 2 from both sides of this
equation we're left with X these twos
cancel out is equal to 2 now let's
validate that this is truly the case
that it works when we're taking the
principal root not all both square roots
or the negative square root let's see
what when you take the principal root we
get the square root of 2 that's our
answer
Plus this 2 minus 2 should be equal to 0
this is for the principal root of 4 is 2
2 minus 2 does indeed equal 0 so this is
a valid solution it's not an extraneous
solution it works with the principal
root let's do one that doesn't involve a
square root let's revolve let's do one
with a higher power root let's say we
have so we have the fourth root of x
squared minus nine is equal to two so
let's say gee Sal what do I do here 4
through that's crazy how do we deal with
a fourth root and it's the same process
when you had a square root we squared it
when you have the fourth root we take it
to the fourth power and just as a bit of
a review this could be completely
written like this
another way to write it would be x
squared minus 9 to the 1/4 power is
equal to 2 these are equivalent
statements just different ways of
writing the fourth root now if we raise
both sides to the fourth power what
happens to this exponent right here if
we raise something to an exponent and
then raise that to another exponent we
multiply the exponents so 1/4 times 4 is
1 so this just becomes x squared minus 9
to the first power or we could just
write x squared minus 9 and that's going
to be equal to 2 to the fourth power 2
to the fourth power is what 2 times 2 is
4 times 2 is 8 times 2 is 16 now we can
just there's two ways we can do it
actually at this point we can add 9 to
both sides of this equation I'll do it
this way in yellow so if you add 9 you
get x squared is equal to 25 take the
square root not just a principal square
root take the positive and negative
square root of both sides of this
equation and you get X is equal to plus
or minus 5 that's one way the other way
if you know sometimes it's confusing
people forget to take the positive and
negative square roots instead to do it
the way we've been doing all along
through solving traditional quadratic
setting them equal to zero so what you
do is you subtract 16 from both sides of
this equation if you do that you get x
squared minus 25 if we subtract 16 from
both sides is equal to zero so these two
are equivalent
this essentially we're just moving the
25 on to the left hand side we're just
subtracting 25 from both sides of this
to get that but what this does is it
puts this in the form of a difference of
squares we know we can rewrite this as X
plus 5 times X minus 5 we went over that
several videos ago and that will be
equal to 0 and if the product of two
numbers is equal to 0 that means that
either one or both of them is equal to 0
so X plus 5 is equal to 0 or X minus 5
is equal to 0 and we get X is equal to
negative 5 or X is equal to positive 5
which is what we got right there now the
one thing we want to make sure
or once against that me neither of these
are extraneous extraneous solutions
because you're taking a fourth root or
when you take something to the fourth
power and negative numbers also
disappear so this is you can kind of is
this a principal fourth root that we're
taking here there's a negative version
of this could have also been valid so
let's make sure that they both work well
whether we put negative five or positive
five here this right here is going to be
twenty five so you get the fourth root
of 25 minus 9 which is the fourth root
of 16 and 16 so this is the fourth root
of 16 which is equal to 16 to the 1/4
power which is indeed 2 so both of these
work when you square either of these you
do indeed get 25